[Applause]
we're just gonna keep doing it oh my
gosh your eyes and person are just like
next-level oh thank you yeah way to go
god yeah wait so you you have been
married for seven years right yes okay
do you have any advice for Max and
Julian up there well congratulations
I mean what an incredible story you know
it's funny because your story reminds me
of like a shot a song Oh
love is stronger than pride and it's
it's it's just your story gives so many
people hope to kind of put pride aside
compromise go with love you understand
what I'm saying man a man that loves I
so what was your first date like with
your wife it was more like a takeover so
exactly that's what every woman says
that when I tell the story so my wife
had was she basically told me that this
other guy was not her boyfriend so I
asked her about him and she said no he's
not my type he's not my boyfriend he's
never been my boyfriend you're my type
oh yeah aggresses the first time she
ever said that yeah and I was like okay
yeah so I think I called it the day
after and was like okay so can we go out
on like Tuesday night she's like no okay
oh just like no reason just like now
he's like no I'm working I was like okay
great well I get it about like Thursday
no I'm working it was like this I have
Monday off that's the day we'll go out
and I was like this okay it's kind of
hot she's bold I think I think it worked
in hindsight it works yeah I excited to
work I think in the moment I was just
like kind of just taken aback like is
she crazy yeah I think I was drawn to
that
I was definitely drawn to that but yeah
and in the first date we actually we
linked up during the day because she was
like I'm gonna go I'm gonna work tonight
but let's do something during the day I
was like add a date sexy so we went to
this like Vietnamese restaurant and we
ate and then didn't want it to end so I
was like what else could I do
what else could I do and she was sitting
there we were talking and we were
talking and she said to me can we get
the first kiss out of the way she got
like I'm feeling you and I'm telling you
right now if it's bad or if it's wack I
just want to go home and never see you
again we're still together
[Applause]
you're now she's your wife and after
seven years like this is the thing I
don't get and I could never date an
actor because I ain't seeing my man with
some other chick up on a filming like
now it's just for work like just the
world yeah that is a different level of
comfortable first of all I am an artist
and it is acting sure as always 100%
acting she just never got weird about it
you know and she's always said she's
always sick of her girlfriends to this
day even to this day will see me they
see me make out with Kobe on Stumptown
and be like you know I don't know how
you do it I don't know how you do it and
she tells him the same thing every time
look he's never given me a reason yeah
to doubt so absolutely
[Applause]
our kids are almost the same age they're
similar ages are your kids into
performing like you sadly yes okay me
too it is it is something that you
probably I don't know about you I tried
to prevent it at all costs and there's
just no way around it
my my daughter who's three who she uh oh
my god with the one eyes she had her
first like Winterfest celebration at her
little preschool oh my god exactly
exactly I didn't know about this this is
a gym nobody told me about so they bring
out all the kids and my daughter was
dead center and she comes out and she's
looking you could tell she's looking out
for her mom and me and I'm like and so
I'm holding the camera she's not looking
over she's not looking over so I start
calling her nickname and then she gives
us like a Miss America wave and I just I
was just like are you experiencing you
said three years old right she's three
so I mean three n'ajjer right is that
been absolutely three days this is a new
term to me I didn't know this well
absolutely choose yeah we have a three
year old boy girl boy okay and he just
destroys everything yeah like a
psychopath just like like just
everywhere that changes yeah it changes
hopefully but she like we couldn't
figure out who she was like for years it
because she's not exactly like my wife
she's not exactly like me she has you
know and I hate this term now because
they only use it for girls they people
call her sassy right and I'm like well
we only use that term for girls oh why
is that for many guys yeah I've never
heard anybody that being said it was one
of those things where she I realized
that she's just like my aunt my aunt
Shanti's in DC she is sweet as pie
but she will cut you if you cross her
you hurt someone in her family she will
cut you she came to set and we were
doing a scene on some time where I was
like I was a a car was being stolen and
the woman whose car I tried to chase
after the car and the woman whose car
was stolen started hitting me when I
tried to help her off the ground and my
wife had explained to her this whole
story about how dad was a superhero and
this was the princess and the thieves
stole princesses carriage and so exactly
she's creative in this way so so my wife
I mean after the tank get up and my
daughter says daddy why did it why did
the princess hit you and I said and I
looked up and my wife was like okay I
was like because I'm trying to get her
car back and she was like where's the
princess I was like gosh she's right
here oh she gonna cut the price she went
up to the princess the actress
it says you don't hit my dad superhero
and she crawled in my arms and hug me
like what do you want a unicorn I'll
find one I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this